et des champions on en parle encore ce
soir peut-être bientôt le Rugby Club de
plaisir champion pourquoi pas
champion de votre division ce serait
déjà pas mal non quel objectif difficile
à atteindre oui après la phase aller le
PRC et troisième de fédéral 3 on peut
dire que vous êtes dans les clous vous
vous tenez vos objectifs pour l'instant
Philippe oui pour l'instant tiens les
objectifs c'est ce qui avait été
programmé en début de saison suite à une
troisième place aussi la saison dernière
donc avec quelques recrues
supplémentaires par rapport à la saison
dernière on se disait qu'il fallait au
moins faire aussi bien pour l'instant on
est dans les clous vous vous parlez des
recrues quatre crus cet été c'est des
joueurs d'expérience que vous avez fait
venir ou revenir au PRC on en avait
parlé c'est 4 4 anciennes plaisirs qui
étaient partis au club de Chevreuse et
qui ont fait le chemin inverse et puis
qui nous rendent bien service quatre
joueurs d'expérience dont deux piliers
qui étaient une denrée rares à plaisir
et qui nous sont bien utiles pour
aborder les joutes difficiles de la
Fédérale 3 effectivement en fin de
saison dernière vous aviez des petits
soucis au niveau de la première ligne il
y avait plus grand monde
on avait des on avait beaucoup de
blessés et puis on s'est retrouvé je
voulais phase finale avec deux juniors
sur les postes de piliers ce qui est
très difficile et s'il aura appris
beaucoup de choses mais on a souffert
quand même en première ligne en début de
saison là ce début de saison il y a
quand même beaucoup de blessés plus que
la saison dernière c'est du quoi
malchance la préparation physique la
rentrée qui a été un peu trop difficile
et du coup ils ont eu du mal à encaisser
après derrière au rugby les accidents
qui se qui ont eu lieu cette année
pendant les matchs sont des accidents
quoi on peut pas très bien on peut pas
agir là-dessus donc là c'est la
malchance l'an dernier on avait fait une
saison complète avec quasiment le même
groupe donc ça avait été porteur de
résultats mais cette année avec cette
fille joueurs de l'équipe première très
rapidement blessé des blessés longue
durée c'est vrai que c'est difficile et
heureusement qu'on a recruté ces quatre
joueurs qui sont potentiels équipe
première
la semaine dernière dernier match de
phase allée votre premier point de bonus
offensif ça c'est une belle récompense
aussi puisque le PRC est quand même à
une philosophie de jeu très offensive
vous allez très vraiment vers l'avant
oui on essaye on essaye on a un groupe
assez jeune avec des gens qui ont envie
de de se passer le ballon qui a envie de
vivre des bons moments et envie des bons
moments si jamais on
produit du jeu sinon c'est c'est un peu
un peu rasant donc pour l'instant ça se
passe comme ça après dans les matchs
plus rugueux plus durs peut-être on sera
obligé de de voir nos objectifs un peu à
la baisse au niveau du jeu l'important
évidemment étant les résultats et cette
qualification qui est attendue par tout
le club les dirige en tête quoi la
semaine dernière pour revenir à ce
dernier match de phase allée aussi il y
avait eu ce petit problème de fin de
match ou la gestion du score était n'est
pas encore acquise on va dire oui on a
beaucoup de mal à finir les matchs on
avait eu la même chose trois semaines
avant qu'entre nos gens qui est une
équipe bas de tableaux aussi qu'on avait
dominé de la tête et des épaules et qui
en match c'était ressuscité un petit peu
du fait aussi de nos lacunes c'est
encore le cas dimanche dernier et
malheureusement quand on mène quatre
essais à zéro on doit jamais se faire
peur en fin de match et c'est peut-être
un domaine dans lequel il va falloir
travailler quoi c'est dû à quoi
l'indiscipline de vos joueurs ou trop de
fautes là non non mais il a raison
je pense qu'il va vous attendre ils vont
vous expliquer ce que c'est la
discipline non mais c'est vrai que dans
les petits carnets justement je note à
la fin de chaque match souvent ces
notions à discipline on est pénalisé
au-delà de de ce qui est permis et c'est
un domaine qui devrait nous faire nous
permettre de progresser et d'avoir de
meilleurs résultats si on est capable de
limiter les pénalités on a une vingtaine
de pénalités contre nous en 10 millions
d'un tiers on fera un grand chemin vers
des fins de masse plus facile pour
comment vous les expliquez comment vous
expliquer vos joueurs se laissent aller
peut-être sur le terrain parfois manque
de concentration ils ont du mal à tenir
80 minutes concentré donc et puis et
puis peut-être la jeunesse du groupe
aussi qui fait que ce manque
d'expérience dans les moments délicats
la fatigue fait que mais on est qu'en 3e
division tout à l'heure car le livre on
parlait dit au niveau là on est vraiment
chez des joueurs amateurs qui jouent au
rugby pour le plaisir et qui n'ont
peut-être pas le recul nécessaire
justement pour gérer ses fins de matchs
quoi justement dans le vestiaire dans
votre groupe vous avez des joueurs
cadres aussi plus âgés qui encadrent un
petit peu et qui pourraient sur la suite
de la saison alors on a les ardeurs des
plus jeunes oui c'est c'est évident que
les quelques jours qu'on a récupéré sont
des jours d'expérience pays ils évoluent
à des postes ou ils sont souvent le nez
dans le gazon pas trop la parole par
contre c'est vrai qu'on a on a la chance
d'avoir depuis deux saisons un capitaine
deuxième ligne François Villard qui
était venu l'an dernier d'ailleurs vous
voir qui est quelqu'un qui a une
certaine aura et qui essaye de faire
passer notre message mais dans un match
difficile à la 80e minute tout le monde
a du mal à rester lucide mais il revient
toujours la même chose que ce soit
football ou le rugby et le football dont
on parlait tout à l'heure avec Carlo
Lille il faut toujours un patron
sur le terrain et puis nous on est on
sert pas à grand-chose pendant les 80
minutes du match on peut faire le bilan
après mais pendant le match on a plus
d'action sur les joueurs mais le groupe
vit bien encore cette saison par rapport
par rapport à la saison dernière oui
c'est un groupe qui est qui s'entend
très bien qui font les avants et les
après match ensemble bon café
un investissement par rapport à au
niveau qui est peut-être pas suffisant
mais bon tous les entraîneurs de club de
ce niveau-là
réclament plus d'investissement et ce
qui risque peut-être de limiter
justement les résultats en fin de saison
pour aller chercher plus haut il va
falloir
peut-être s'investir plus revenir à
l'objectif de cette saison donc les
playoffs on va dire que c'est un peu un
combat à 3 pour deux places évidemment
il y a Beauvais Orléans qui sont qui
sont vraiment détachés maintenant
premier deuxième plaisir et troisième et
ça va être la lutte va être vraiment
acharné avec Pontault-Combault et
l'Union des bords de Marne oui c'est des
clubs qui se valent tout ça en dehors
des deux premiers qui ont pas du tout
les mêmes moyens qui qui tirent dans une
autre cour que la nôtre bon ces trois
clubs là vont batailler jusqu'à la fin
et ça sera sûrement
les blessés éventuels qui feront la
différence ou l'investissement des
jugements des joueurs sur toute une
saison et pas seulement sur trois quatre
mois prochain match à domicile ça sent
mort c'est ça ce weekend ce weekend
contre sa mort qu'on avait battu à
l'aller à l'extérieur en tout cas on
suivra la saison du PRC jusqu'au playoff
et bonne continuation Philippe merci
d'être venu sur le plateau